cette maison vous la partagez avec Jane
ce n'est plus la maison du célibataire
la maison du solitaire que vous avez été
longtemps c'est une maison de famille
[Musique]
c'est l'intérieur de sa tête il y a un
côté rêve c'est pas tellement en maison
de famille il y a
cette chambre qui est uniquement lui et
oui
il y a le chambre des enfants qui est
la salle de billard j'ai fait les
concessions
j'ai gardé le sens de un sens personnel
de esthétique et que j'ai mis en dans
l'espace comme ça dans cette dans cette
maison donc cette maison c'est une sorte
de tableau dans l'espace oui je suis
très maniaque sur quand j'ai trouvé la
place idéale d'un objet et bien il ne
doit plus bouger